all right welcome to the unauthorized
recap of the 2015 sinquefield Cup I was
up there with these guys for 50 plus
hours spanning nine ten days and so I
got a lot a lot of Secrets I can reveal
tonight okay so first game first round
we have Aronian playing a carry-on Oh or
as a Mario likes to call them corona
right yes yeah all right so aronian
starts out with the deep on and yeah
corona plays a g6 not recommended Knight
f3 so so now why it's got a really good
setup with his nights while black is
kind of a boxed in here Bishop e7 Bishop
f4 black gets cancelled and now white it
can play the E pawn and and this Bishop
is free hitting c7 so now it out c5 so
what can you tell me about both of
blacks bishops in this position yeah
they can't even move without getting
lost though not very good very good so
he moves his night and you know you
don't want to take it here because then
he'd have a you know a decent pawn in
the middle attacking the night even
though it's doubled so he just activates
his rook so it takes so you think we're
going to take back like that nope take
back with the rook keep your pawns all
nice all right so big moment here big
moment all right so so what do you think
why should do here is a c6 excellent and
we don't have to worry about this
because pawn takes Bishop takes check
context back however Queen takes or even
Bishop takes doesn't matter really he's
going to have you know we're going to
have five pieces as opposed to his four
pieces even though he's up a pawn so
we're theoretically tied in the in the
number count but with a piece count we
have one two three four five and he's
only got the fort so there would be good
for white so obviously a carry-on Oh
doesn't doesn't go into that variation
he simply moves his uh his night back to
f6 okay so a three stops stops the
Bishop b4 threat a five Bishop to d3 you
know aiming at the Kings side here so
night up now I carry on toes put them to
the test again right he plumped his
other knight on e4 and we didn't take it
you think we're going to do it now no
reason to we can just retreat our work
back and everything's fine and now carry
on Oh plays a very dubious move here the
move f6 remember remember whenever you
have a temptation to play that move f6
don't play it look for a better move
like a better move in this position is
just simply Bishop the d6 you know
you're activating your Bishop put them
to the test f6 not a good idea so clean
up and now he's going to make f6 look
like not the worst move because he's
just going to keep well he finally
Bishop the d6 here and then after castle
he's going to play g5 you think this is
a good good idea for a carry-on oh to be
pushing all his pawns in front of his
King the answer is no
in some positions as we'll see later on
in actually this tournament you know
players actually do push their King site
pawns to to get an advantage even though
their kings over there but in this
position it's just not safe enough so
after takes Knight takes look at this
big line he's got aim and toward the
king he's got a lot of things cooking
here so so he's going to play rook to e1
it looks like a very passive move right
like this is not even a semi-open file
but you know he's going to eventually
play efore and when he does he's going
to be in a lot of trouble a floor night
back so now black plays the move d 5 so
this is a Rodian time to strike with e
for here and now they play F by so now
all of a sudden things have gotten
really interesting luckily White's king
is safe Black's king isn't so now
there's a lot of options right that what
way can take you can take the deep on
the e pawn or the f1 bottom line is we
got to get our I file open I would
probably take back I probably take this
pawn but but I guess he was thinking it
might that might happen and then the eep
on the e-file would still be closed so
white actually plays the move f3 we're
just totally different than f6 okay it
doesn't have all the drawbacks so so
after f3 especially because obviously
black does not have a dark squared
bishop okay where white does so this
could be a big burden on up on black
later on as we'll see so f3
maybe not the best but he takes takes
and now in this position you know I
don't know so he plays work a 5 and so
now he's got to get that efile open so
he just takes the pawn some night takes
and now he delivers the check all thanks
to having that f prime move so King up
here and now we might have some some
exciting moves for white does anybody
have any uh any idea what white should
play here obviously we can't play Queen
takes pawn check because that rook is
covering the pawn if you look at all
four of your pieces for white here are
five pieces right the rook the Queen the
night the rook the bishop who do you
think is doing the absolute least in
this position of those forward pieces
tonight right he's not protecting
anything is not attacking anything you
just sit in there okay so now where do
we want them to go so f3 f3 is not a bad
idea because because it looks like hey
I'm forking this pawn in that pond but
II for it just has a lot more bite
because you see and this in this
variation you're attacking a lot of his
squares in his territory as opposed to
just two when you're on f3 when you're
on e4 you're attacking one two three
four obviously the big tour we're aiming
at is a half six and gee pop okay
well first things first he plays d5 and
now he goes 44 okay yeah we try and let
them take the pawn first okay so
Knightly for and now he's got something
cooking here all right good but notice
black gets a fork in now okay so we
don't want to lose an exchange you know
so white needs to come up with a really
scary move in this position a scary move
is one that you know makes your opponent
tremble you know it's a it's you know
it's usually when you're getting a one
of your power pieces way down in his uh
in this territory you know as close as
the king as possible so the scary move
in this position is clean up sorry is
like all right I'm taking that free rook
so now take the pawn threatening
threatening a lot Queen check queen
check you know we're doing good so you
think you should take our other rook
probably not probably that would lead to
us to checkmate okay so instead he plays
a defense move Bishop f5 okay so so our
works order attack and this Bishop is a
major defender right so let's just
attack the bishop so he protects the
bishop so notice we can't tell me about
this rook it's undefended right so
you could just take it
and then we'll get this big check in and
because if if work takes the night
obviously Queen will take the Queen so
so we got a lot of great tactics if if
he if we just take the up to Bishop
right off the bat instead he plays 96
check which allows him to play rook
takes c6 so now rook takes f5 because if
well Queen takes we'll take the Queen so
now his queen is under attack and his
rook is under attack it's not going very
well for him so he offers a queen trade
so we have two options here for white
luckily they're both good alright if
they weren't both good we be kicking
ourselves for not playing rook takes up
five earlier in this position but
luckily he's okay so obviously uh when
black plays Queen to g6 what two moves
can we would we want to consider here
yeah rook g5 that's probably what I
would have played but instead he takes
Queen takes rook takes Knight up notice
we can't take the pond because the rook
is on a five so so I ronnians got a
great idea let's just start pushing our
point is two away right no reason to
keep them to away when we can just keep
pushing them up all right so Brooke goes
back to stop the Queen so now we can
take that pawn and we're right behind
the pawn so things are going going
better for us so Brooke gets right in
front of the pawn on the queening square
so carry on is doing everything he
possibly can to stop
this up pon from queening at this point
so rook attacks the night if we go here
that's not very good right because we'll
just pin it right so he goes Knight up
so he's got two attackers now on this
pawn and we only have one defender what
could we possibly do here Bishop attacks
the night and once again if he plays
Knight takes it's going to be big
trouble right cause now Bishop attacks
the rook he's got to move and the rook
takes neck check so he plays Knight to
d6 once again attacking the queening
square again so I have a feeling he's
going to play Bishop there so Knight
takes the rook Bishop takes the rook and
now King f6 white plays if you know the
answer you know it might not look as
miraculous but but when you see a plate
on the board you're like wow the guy is
really good so what move do you think
white plays the stun black keep in mind
you know he's just one away from getting
a queen but unfortunately this Bishop is
in the way so everybody can maybe do a
clearance sacrifice as we actually see
in the next game we got something good
going anybody anybody know the move or
see the move or want to just shout it
out Bishop the g6 excellent Keith yeah
right because the point is if we take it
we get a queen and we're great and if we
take the pawn we win the night ok so
either way White is crushing here so so
that was Aronian in a game one here so
unfortunately
carry on I'll start out 01 and then he
had to play the world champion in the
next round okay so so let's see if he
does any better in this game so Bishop
b5 right and for a six you know what i
recommend here just take the night like
I wasn't bluffing give them double pawns
play h3 and then get castled you know
that's how you really should be playing
the word Lopez unfortunately as we'll
see after a six he plays Bishop a four
and then you know just count up how many
how many moves he makes with this Bishop
throughout the game and obviously uh
Carlson is getting free moves in like
with b5 and and now he has to play a 3-1
because he doesn't want a before to be
played and now so his bishop can retreat
to a two with black ever place up night
to a five so so they moving the Knights
around a little bit probably the best
thing to do is just is just cut your
losses and play Bishop takes Knight in
this position but instead he goes back
to a two so so just too much too many
bishop moves you know bye-bye carry on
oh I mean that's what happens when you
play Bishop b5 and don't take that night
you know if you play Bishop before you
know you're lucky it doesn't get trapped
so Knight takes Queen takes all right so
now this bishops actually doing
something already is on the same Lane as
the queen but it does Carlson really
doesn't seem to mind all right protects
so he tries to break it open here takes
takes right fi so now H for it so this
is a pretty interesting maneuver by
carlson here so he attacks the rook ok
so now the rook attacks the bishop
program it's got a really cool way to to
protect this bishop notice the rook is
on the same file as the bishop so he
takes the pawn and now the queen is
under attack right so so when he takes
back all of a sudden rook is protecting
the bishop ok and now what we got to
watch out because our queen is now under
attack as well so obviously Carlson sees
it and he moves the Queen g3 king of
fate Bishop back now a43 for all right
so they're moving some ponds around
kingi ate fish of attacks the pawn but
it's protected by the bishop and the
Queen so rook up alright work to be for
this is this the only I guess Carlson
saw further than I could ever see
because if you know somebody attacks
your pawn right you probably want to try
to try to either defend it or make a
threat greater equal like play Queen to
d8 so if work takes the pawn right we'll
get the a point but Carlson's like I'm
going to get that pawn back don't worry
about it so he just moves his King
so rook takes so g6 pawn takes pawn
takes Queen to be three so now notice
the Knights under attack but carry on Oh
has got two men a man down at the
bishops oh so he's like all right I'll
save the bishop with Bishop c6 and so he
saves the night then look he got the he
got the pawn back okay so I guess he
knew what he was doing all along here so
so this is a really interesting tank
control for the sink filled cup you have
two hours with no time delay and no
increment for your first 40 moves once
you make the 40th move then you get a an
additional hour and thirty second
increment but in this first time control
your time is always running so it
happened in a couple games where these
guys got under a minute and they have to
make you know 568 moves possibly in less
than a minute some can some can't so so
the time is really on here so Bishop up
so takes takes Queen up night back and
now another scary move all right
whatwhat's about the only scary move we
have in this position they're just clean
up three you know an attack sir rook
your queen is you know it's just a night
throw away from getting the King so it's
it's getting getting good so if he's not
careful here he might just lose so
unfortunately with his he had about ten
seconds here Karen oh did to make two
moves so once rook plays it looks like a
very natural move okay right he just
attacked my queen and rook you know I
can just take it right the preferred
moves in this position airy the queen
bee three or cling to a four but after
he takes and rooked a
he's in a lot of trouble huh his queen
is under attack and thanks to that scary
movie earlier Queen up three we're also
threatening check the mate so
unfortunate he made the 40th move in the
nick of time but unfortunately it was
not the best so so even a even the top
grandmasters when they're in time
trouble can make a serious serious
errors okay so so at this point I carry
on Oh resigned so here's a aronian plane
anish giri both of these guys had the
exact same strategy going into the
tournament just don't lose games because
neither have lost the game but Aronian
did it a little better because he got
two more wins than Giri had wind so
aronian finished with six points while
Giri even though undefeated only
finished with five alright so erroneous
got the old white pieces start out see
for the English you know they bring out
the Knights this is a good good wave for
Giri to play you know if your opponent's
playing a little bit passive and get d5
in just do it so take take you know in
this position you'll the Knights attack
the bishop is coming down on this night
you know instead of making a complicated
you know just just move move the night
out of the way you know castle so now
gear he wants to get castled as well and
for each 6 a-3 so Bishop up night up so
he's kind of tempting of as we seen in
the other games he erroneous kind of
tempting Giri to play a 5 and push his
King side ponds up and geary you decided
he's going to play more solid he plays a
night the d4 in this position instead of
falling for moving the F pawn
and getting it so so this is this is the
reason why I showed you guys this game
it's a very interesting thing he does so
Queen up for so Bishop takes f3 so white
obviously has three different ways to
capture this Bishop back the Queen the
bishop or the pawn believe it or not
aronian chooses the ponds which look at
what this does it give some double ponds
obviously and it gives them an isolated
deep on so so the only way you should be
able to do this because obviously it
can't be right is if you think ahead so
so now what do you think his plans his
long long term plans might be as white
here Knight f6 checkin maybe and just
bust them open later there it would be
nice if we could get it but we it would
be a lot of Hope Chest we'd have to
distract the Queen off this uh this
diagonal and then and then we'd have to
have our queen on the G file and then we
could play Knight to f6 because our the
poem would be pinned but the long-term
plans I think aronian was going for but
I'm no super GM as I think he's going to
take control of the e-file eventually
and then play f4 f5 and get it on from
there so let's see let's see if that's
actually what happens alright so black
plays Knight d5 attacks the Queen so
Queen g4 so so okay the G pawns in the
pen so so Knight f6 is still not looking
like an option because now he's got a
night and a queen defending it but you
never know so c6 very good move by a
giri you know like look the rooks on the
C file it's not going
anywhere and now this night good luck
ever getting this night off of d5 so
okay so out for okay so we got to start
pushing that pond so he's pushing the a
pawn and now White's gonna start pushing
his pawns alright so we saw this tactic
again so Mario you know this is a tactic
you use a lot so it's very
underestimated huh so uh maybe maybe you
play you play good huh so rook see to
all right night back to e4 here offers
the trade yeah I would get rid of that
night too and it was pretty good so
Bishop takes so Queen attacks the rook
notice it is defended by the Queen
though but just because it's only
defended by one person doesn't mean it's
a it's very safe okay so rook to e1
threatening of course to play rook takes
Queen takes and then Queen takes the
rook so obviously Giri is going to see
this you'll take Queen takes moves is
rook back and now obviously what move
does white make to to give them at least
a little advantage so Brooks e5 well
which c5 unfortunately would not be good
because it being the same lane is this
bishop but it is a rook move which file
do you think we're after here do we want
to play control the C file or the e-file
so now so now plan 14 Aronian is working
okay he's got the e-file now well I
thought that's what he would play but
first he plays Queen to e4 alright maybe
he wants us clean up in front there all
right so all right I mean he should know
no better than the me what he wants yeah
I mean
you'd rather have your queen centralized
on e4 then on you 10 I agree I agree all
right so Queen c5 bishop so now he's
getting f5 and all right so now and now
aronian really goes for it here he just
goes for f6 just trying to bust them
open so you might as well take going to
clean up queen attacks the Queen
obviously doesn't want to trade all
right so now if aronian want to play
Bishop efore in this game what is the
only move and we only have one move to
prevent a an inevitable checkmate Bishop
e7 unfortunately leads to a check mate
check mate
there was a it was a good try I mean
Bishop the g7 yeah yeah much better
because after check the White Queen has
nothing to do and he's got everything
covered but aronian didn't play that
instead he plays a rook back to see to
giving up the e-file and obviously a
brownie does not want to strain up his
pawns in fact he'd rather have his own
set of double pawns then pin to repair
his have five stops stops him from
playing at five and and they get they
get it and it's like all right the
positions equal will we just call it a
draw okay so now we get a Nakamura game
okay he played a Wesley so the Battle of
a to top 10 Americans and it didn't
disappoint here it didn't disappoint
Nakamura has a black and we'll see how
how is Nakamura really even watch from
his perspective how he wasn't afraid to
push his King side pawns because there
is a there is a good situation for him
to do so so in this position I would
play f3 here actually and followed by a
bishop III Queen d2 and I'm going to
play h4 h5 Bishop h6 and try to get you
but Wesley plays Knight f3 hey so castle
Bishop e2 kind of passive g5 when I'm
playing white in this position I always
uh I always want to play d5 whenever
they play e5 that way he cannot get any
counter play in the center
Wesley's actually where I will obviously
playing it different than i would i
would not want to be castling King side
so i guess in this variation it's okay
how he plays it so white gets castled
and knight c6 almost invites d5 and
nakamura actually likes this because
white is castle on the same side the
King side as as Wesley is so their
castle on the same side the center is
nothing's going to happen in the center
or it's going to take them a long time
to gank counterplay so so now not going
to work like yeah I'm going to I'm going
to start getting by my pawns up there
now Bishop e3 once again they're just
inviting people to attack them so g5
notice in this position even though the
app pond has been pushed to f five nines
you're not f6 there's no way why you can
get any kind of checks in here so now as
least trying to break open this get get
get some block get something rolling on
the C file Nakamura is relentless so so
so the idea of night to be five is like
okay I want the C file you know for my
rook not my night but I mean it's just
you know now you're nice on a three but
you do have the C file open for you so
hope it was worth it
alright so now Wesley's got everybody on
the C file so eat so if he can you know
maintain this attack over here like not
let it get too far the C file should be
a should do something so he attacks the
rook rook moves obviously now bishop
moves to h6 what is on the same diagonal
as this bishop here the rook excellent
so now Nakamura is going to use a
clearance sacrifice here to to get them
so h h4 voluntarily removing the
defender of G for Wesley can't resist he
can't resist so now in that Kimura just
goes for boom so now the rooks attacked
it's a pawn takes and knocking boys like
I don't even want your rook buddy I want
your king and so now Knight takes e4
because if F takes e4 we're just going
to check them and then and then this we
don't want your book will play Bishop e3
and whites just crushed there's there's
no way you're going to withstand all the
checkmates so he doesn't was Lee doesn't
take he moves his rook off of the c1 so
now he's just going to keep keep taking
stuff so work takes up three just go for
it obviously Bishop takes up three would
just be a very very very very bad okay
so so instead is like okay I'll take
I'll take your Bishop on d 7 so Rick
shucks
obviously if Bishop takes Queen takes
mate so King g2 so now Bishop to e3
white the fight decides to defend with
Bishop the g3 so obviously we can just
take it so he takes it rook takes the
rook and we got a night check King up we
got to keep checking well he decides to
go for the discovered check here so you
would not want to be white in this
position your King can't move and it's
about ready to get discovered checked so
you can just hope for the best attack
the Queen night takes check King up and
night to their interesting so he decides
to protect with night up protecting h3
so let's see we could just take it
though instead he wants to give another
check there's a good idea because now
after king here who do you think we're
going to get involved with some chucks
now the rook we better all right work f8
now notice Queen 2h7 is not checkmate
because the rook protects so is there
anything we can do
luckily nakamori notice how it in this
end here you know there was a lot of a
lot of checks but also a lot of just
waiting moves you know so Nakamura has
got one more a waiting move before he
delivers the fatal blow maybe not maybe
he just went for the fatal huh good work
of six so King takes well don't even
worry about what I was thinking that
okay so King takes Knight e for he's got
one more move here or he's got it
actually he's got their word he's got
he's got three moves he can do I don't
think any of them are any good though
and now I finally see the checkmate
hopefully everybody at home can see the
check made here notice this King he's
about ready to get checkmated here on c8
so you better find a checkmate really
quick or else Queen to ca checkmates
coming Queen g5 excellent yep the king
is stopping all all the king from
growing there yep so that was a nakamura
school when he finished a tie for second
place with Carlson Geary and a couple
others alright so do you everybody want
to see a ronnians big big draw at the
end whenever you're playing in a
tournament it's very very very good to
read the cross tables know who's in your
section know how many points you need
aronian knows all he needs is a draw to
clinch the championship so guess what
that's what you should be going for you
can worry about your rating points later
and everything you know if you go to the
tournament you're not going there to go
949 you're going there to win first
place to get 75,000 to get all the Grand
Prix points you know grandchester oh
yeah Grand Prix you got a grand chest to
our points yes
alright so a roni actually has the black
pieces against topol of here alright so
Ali weeds is a draw so check Queens
attack in the bishop and the King so
knight c6 is the only good move tax the
bishop check you know no reason to move
your bishop around a hundred times in
the opening alright so he gives them
double pawns here yeah excellent in this
position Aronian went Bart you know his
poem was attacked twice be five attacks
the Queen he's not afraid a 6 e for okay
so so now toppa loves getting a big
center here alright so the bishops are
both off en shadowed and now white got
cancelled here what do we do as black do
we dare castle and if we do dare castle
which way to the left the King side or
the queenside King say up that's where
you did I guess he figured his night
could fulfill the role of a pond if need
be and he could always play h8 rook g8
for even more defense so even though you
have a you know an open file if you can
get enough players to act like pawns
maybe you can try it yeah if I was a
topple off here I would have played half
for but meeting all right you got to go
for it
all right once again the beef palm was
attacked and and they decided to just do
their own thing here so now Aronian is
down upon but I think he thinks he's
going to get it back because you removes
the defender of d4 here so Bishop takes
and now after takes Queen up and now
Aronian has a moment of truth you played
III or do you just take the pawn so he
chooses I think probably because all in
here was a draw is just to eliminate any
kind of pawns on on Whiteside here and
just get that advantage and now total of
realizes shoot I mean I've facing two
pawns over here I'm just going to go for
he's actually going to go for the draw
believe it or not rook takes Knight
aronian tries to play remove the
defender here Rick takes check hoping
hoping they'll take back with the Queen
obviously topa love's not going to fall
for that and so once he he just he'll
gladly take that and check and they'll
just check each other obviously if the
position arises three times on the board
rather in a row or not in this case it
would be in a row the game is a draw and
that's how Aronian became seventy five
thousand dollars richer alright so that
was the distinct feel Cobra was a lot of
fun
Oh